>>Male Presenter: My name's Scott Giambastiani.
I'm one of the chefs here at Google.
Thanks for coming today.
In a couple of minutes, I wanted to introduce
Barb Stuckey, but before that, I'd like to
give a little bit of background on why she's
here today.
[clears throat]
Barb Stuckey has been a food industry professional
for the last 20 years.
She spent her formative years in a Chinese
restaurant with her best friend's parents,
outside of Baltimore.
After college, Barb learned that the food
service business from the vantage point of
Kraft, back then General Foods, also Brinker
International, the company that operates Chili's,
Macaroni Grill, and Corner Bakery, as well
as Whole Foods.
She later earned a graduate degree from Cornell
University Hotel School.
Barb is currently executive vice president
for marketing at Mattson in Foster City, the
country's largest independent developer of
foods and beverages for the chain restaurant
and retail food industries.
Barb is known as the food trend, innovator,
consumer, insights, and product development
expert.
Throughout her career, she's written articles
for journals such as The Morning Cup, and
industry newsletter distributed to about 6000
plus food executives, and Culinary Currents.
[clears throat] She also wrote the opinion
pieces for the San Francisco Chronicle and
Q&A column for Chow Magazine, now known as
chow.com.
In 2008, she was awarded co-authorship of
the opening chapter, the business of new product
development of the first textbook to be published
for the Research Chef's Association.
When published in 2012, it will be called
Applied Cornology.
The blending of culinary arts and food science
and technology in food product development.
More importantly, now, today, she's here with
us.
Barb's daily job at Mattson requires her to
taste food and figure out how to make it better.
After more than a decade of doing this, she's
honed her tasting skills, which she's going
to show you to do today, and shares this insight
through the science of taste that's written
to the general public.
It's my pleasure to welcome, for the first
time to Google, Barb Stuckey.
[applause]
>>Barb Stuckey: Thank you.
Thanks.
Thanks for that welcome, Scott.
Now I've lost my-- oh, here we go.
Thanks to Google for having me.
I'm going to get started in just a second,
but most importantly, I need five guinea pig,
I mean volunteers, to experience the sensory
demo with me.
I got one, two, three.
I need two more.
Four, five.
Okay, if you guys would come take a seat up
front, and on your way up, if you would take
a tasting plate.
We're going to-- Everybody else in the audience
is going to experience these experiments vicariously
through your five colleagues.
Yes, you can put it on the plate.
And then, afterwards, if there's any of these
experiments that they're going to do that
you'd like to do, you can hang after.
I've got some extras.
All right.
So I'm going to tell you a little bit more
about me, myself, and then I'm going to tell
you why I wrote this book called Taste What
You're Missing.
Then we're going to go into the content of
the book, which is basically about how we
taste.
We're going to do some experiments.
And then at the end, I'll have a little bit
of time for questions and answers.
Okay.
A little bit about me.
You heard from Scott that I have pretty much
spent my entire career in food.
I am now a professional food developer.
--You can put them on your laps and relax.
[laughs]-- I am a professional food developer.
Our development labs are in Foster City, about
20 miles north of here.
We work for some of the largest multinational
food companies in the world, like Kraft and
Kellogg's, and General Mills, Starbucks, McDonald's.
And then we work for small start-up food businesses,
entrepreneurs who want to introduce new foods,
food businesses.
My job is to come up with these food business
ideas and then to work with my colleagues,
who are food technologists and chefs, and
in the case of about 10 of them, they are
both food technologists and chefs, they have
dual degrees.
My job is to take these ideas that exist in
my head and tell them how to make them come
to life.
We do that through a process we call protosepting.
In the process of protosepting, I found myself
side by side with my food technologists and
chef colleagues, 15 years ago when I started
in this business, not knowing what the hell
was happening.
Why would I taste something that was as simple
as a tortilla chip and say, "Yeah, I like
B better than A and C." And they would taste
that same tortilla chip and they would get
so much more sensory output from it.
So I set out looking for a book.
I was looking for this book that would explain
to me what was happening when I put food in
my mouth and chew and swallow.
I looked and I looked and I looked.
That book did not exist.
So I ended up having to learn through a painful
process of experience, what was happening
as I was tasting in the lab.
About five years ago, I decided that that
book that I'd wanted 15 years ago, I was going
to write it.
I set out on a process of doing some research
into this field of sensory science.
That's the result.
My book is the result of that experience.
The book is called Taste What You're Missing.
It's basically about how we taste.
There are three sections to the book.
The first one is about the five senses, because
we don't really think about the fact that
food and eating is a multisensory experience.
We say it's about taste: I like the taste
of something.
Well, actually, if you like the taste of chocolate,
for example, you like the way it looks, you
like the way it feels, you like the way it
sounds, you like the way it smells, and you
like the way it tastes.
The second part of the book then goes into
great depth about our sense of taste.
There are only five things that human beings
can detect using only that one sense: sweet,
sour, bitter, salt, and umami.
If it's not one of those five things, you're
not using your sense of taste alone.
So chocolate that I mentioned, the taste of
chocolate is sweet and bitter, perhaps a little
bit sour.
That's it.
It's the only tastes you get from chocolate.
Everything else that's happening that makes
chocolate so wonderful: the melting quality
of chocolate, which just happens to melt at
human body temperature, precisely at human
body temperature, that's the texture of it.
The aromas of the roasty, toasty, beany notes,
that's the smell of it.
And of course, it makes a sound when we snap
it.
Visually, it should look beautifully dark
and glossy and chocolatey.
The end of the book brings all these things
together: your five senses, the five basic
tastes, and then layers onto it other stuff
that impacts the way you experience food:
of course your culture, your personality,
your experience, and your brain.
Okay.
We're going to start now, go through each
one of the five senses.
I'm going to start with-- I told you, there
are only five things that we can taste.
I'm going to tell you a little bit of a story
about how I came to appreciate my sense of
taste.
Now you have to go back with me to Foster
City, in the lab, a couple of years ago.
We had been hired by this company to develop
new appetizers for the restaurant industry.
This is my job, to think up new appetizers
that haven't been done.
I new right away what I wanted to do.
I grew up in Baltimore.
My dad used to grow tomatoes.
I wanted to do fried green tomatoes, which
he used to make every Sunday for breakfast.
So I enlisted one of my chefs to start prototyping
this.
It turns out, because we were going to sell
these in huge quantities, frozen, that sliced
green tomatoes were too flimsy and too wet.
They weren't going to work.
So she said, "What if we do fried green cherry
tomatoes?"
"All right, let's try that."
Then my chef came back to me and said, "You
know what, we can't find the green ones.
I can only get red ones to start prototyping.
Is that okay?"
So I said, "All right: fried red cherry tomatoes.
Let's try it."
We decided we would put a cornmeal crust on
it.
I get a page one day, and it says, "Barb,
please come to the lab.
The prototype is ready for you to taste."
Now this is my favorite part of my job.
This is when the idea that exists up here
comes to life and I get to taste it.
I walk into the lab.
My chef is dropping these beautiful cornmeal-crusted
cherry tomatoes into the fryer.
They're bubbling around in the fryer, and
they're golden-coated.
I know this is going to be a great idea.
Just as she pulls the basket out of the fryer,
shakes it, I reach my hand into the basket
to grab one of these lovely prototypes and
put it in my mouth, I hear her start to scream.
[screams] [laughter] That 375 degree cherry
tomato, I spit it out across the room, along
with the roof of my mouth.
[laughter] My entire tongue was traumatized.
Burned off a lot of taste buds.
I thought, "There goes my tasting career.
I'm a professional taster who can't taste.
What am I going to do?"
Well, lucky for me, taste is such an important
sense that these taste buds that I burned
off would regenerate in 10 to 14 days.
In fact, they're constantly regenerating on
your tongue, every 10 to 14 days.
Taste is a contact sense.
Think about it.
Food has to be in contact with your tongue
for you to be able to experience it.
That's different than the sense of smell or
hearing or sight, which can happen from a
distance.
But taste has to be a contact sense.
So it's important that these taste buds on
your tongue work.
We also found out very recently that there
are taste buds in your gut.
Now, not just food sensor receptors down there,
but actual taste buds.
Of course, this makes good intuitive sense
when you think about it, because your stomach
needs to know what to do with the food you've
just eaten.
It needs to tell your body how to start digesting
it.
So it would make sense that it says, "Oh,
there's some sweetness here" or "There's some
protein here."
Now I'm going to talk a little bit about this
very important sense.
There are three things that determine your
taster type.
Your taster type is how you experience the
taste world.
Each one of us experiences the taste world
very, very, very differently.
But remember, I'm only talking about this
one sense.
We'll get to the other senses later.
The three things that impact your taster type
are your anatomy, your genetics, and your
personal history.
Let's start with anatomy.
When I'm talking about anatomy, I'm talking
about the anatomy of your tongue.
This is my fiancé's tongue.
He has dyed it blue with blue food coloring,
which you can do at home with your friends
or your kids.
Just take a little McCormick blue food coloring
and paint your tongue with it.
[laughter] Okay.
So your tongue is painted blue, and you've
got these little taste buds that are going
to pop up.
You want to take a reinforcement and put it
on your tongue and count the taste buds in
that little circle.
What you're looking for is the density of
taste buds on your tongue, because the density
of taste buds indicates whether or not you
are a hypertaster or what some people call
a supertaster.
Some people have this incredible density of
taste buds.
Their entire tongue is densely packed with
these taste buds.
Then some people at the other end of the spectrum
have just a few dotted around.
This person, whose tongue is covered with
taste buds, will experience the tastes as
three times as intense as the person who has
less taste buds.
Imagine that you've got all these taste buds.
Something that's bitter to you is going to
be much more bitter than it is to someone.
Salty is saltier, sweet is sweeter, spicy
is spicier.
We know this by counting the taste buds on
your tongue.
[scraping sound]
I've offered-- I've asked these volunteers
to come up.
We're going to paint their tongues-- No, I'm
kidding, we're not.
We're not going to paint their tongues, but
we're going to talk about the next thing,
which correlates with the anatomy of your
tongue, and that is a genetic marker for supertaster
or hypertaster.
In one of your cups, you should have a little
white strip.
This is a strip that is-- Do you have one?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Stuckey: Okay.
This is a strip that is impregnated with a
specific compound that will tell you whether
or not you fall into this hypertaster category,
with lots of taste buds on your tongue and
the genetic disposition to be able to taste
bitter things, or in the middle, where most
people exist, or on the end which I called
tolerant tasters.
It means that you don't have a lot of taste
buds, and you're very tolerant of bitter taste.
Go ahead and take that piece of paper, stick
it in your mouth, and just put it in your
mouth, close your mouth, and just suck on
it for a couple seconds.
Now I'd like you to tell me.
Put it in your mouth for-- just don't swallow
it.
Just put it on your tongue.
[laughter] On a scale of 0 to 10, 0 being
"Tastes like paper" 10 being "It's the most
intense thing I've ever experienced."
Give me a number between 0, paper, and 10,
most intense thing I've ever experienced.
Okay, take it out now.
Some of you probably hate me.
There's a cracker there you can cleanse your
palate with.
Anyone have a really, really intense experience
there?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Stuckey: Moderate?
>>Male #1: Yeah, a little bit above moderate.
>>Stuckey: And what did you taste?
>>Male #2: Bitter.
>>Stuckey: Bitter.
Anyone else taste bitter?
Yes?
A little bitter?
Okay.
I think everybody on our panel is a taster,
which means that they, like the majority of
the population, fall in this middle group
of people that have a good number of taste
buds on their tongue.
The last thing that indicates your taster
type is your personal history.
Now that I've told you about my trauma with
the tomato, there are other things you can
do that traumatize your mouth.
There are surgeries or viruses that you might
have had that can damage your taste nerves.
If you've had your wisdom teeth pulled, for
example.
When you have your wisdom teeth pulled, it
happens very close to one of the taste nerves,
the chorda tympani nerve.
That, if you snip it, can take out taste in
the front part of your mouth.
If you've had ear infections as a kid.
If you had those recurrent ear infections,
that may have damaged your taste nerve.
There's a lot of things that can go into your
personal experience that are going to layer
on top of your genetics and your anatomy.
Okay.
So now we're going to move onto more pleasant
tastes.
We're going to start with sweet.
Taste-- Let me just say for a minute, the
sense of taste is so important that we wire
it so that it's constantly regenerating.
We call taste the deciding sense.
You put a food in your mouth, you have to
make a decision whether or not you're going
to swallow it.
You swallow it, you get nourished.
You spit it out, you don't.
You swallow something that's poisonous, you
can kill yourself.
You spit it out, you don't.
Taste is about making decisions.
Smell, on the other hand, is about enjoyment.
We're going to talk about smell in a minute.
But, back to taste.
Sweet.
We know that babies are born loving sweet.
They come out of the womb, you can put a little
sugar in their mouth, and they will light
up.
Love sugar.
Why are we wired this way?
Why do we love sugar?
Why do we love the taste "sweet?"
>>Male #1: Energy?
>>Stuckey: Absolutely.
It's a flashing neon sign for calories.
Sweet equals calories.
If, God forbid, there was a little baby crawling
around back when we were cavemen, looking
for food in any way, shape, or form we could
get it, you find something sweet, a little
baby finds something sweet, they can nourish
themselves.
So we're wired from the get-go to like sweet.
Sour.
This one's a little bit more complicated.
Why do you think we can detect sour?
What is it that sour communicates to us?
>>Male #2: Vitamin C.
>>Stuckey: Vitamin C?
>>Female #1: Not ripe.
>>Stuckey: Not ripe!
Yes.
Exactly.
You're the first person I've ever gotten that
from.
I've given this to hundreds and hundreds of
people.
That's exactly right.
If you take an apple off the tree, you take
a bite of it and it's too sour, might give
you stomachache.
Well, not only that, but at the point where
that sweetness and the sourness in the apple
are at that perfect balance where you take
the bite and you go, "That's a good apple",
that is when the apple is at its nutritional
peak.
It has the highest level of micro-nutrients.
After that point, it starts to decline.
It's an indicator of ripeness, exactly right.
What else does sour do?
What does it tell us?
When the milk goes bad, it goes what?
>>audience: Sour.
>>Stuckey: Sour.
Right.
So it's a spoilage mechanism.
It's a spoilage indicator.
You taste something that's not supposed to
be sour and it's sour, you don't eat it.
Protective.
Bitter.
Now let's talk about bitter.
My people that are sitting up here just experienced
bitter.
What is it about bitter that we need to know?
Why do we innately reject bitter?
>>Male #3: Poisonous.
>>Stuckey: Poisonous.
Exactly.
Most poisons taste bitter.
What's even more interesting, though, is most
bitter things are poisonous in the right quantity.
So you say, "What a second, I drink coffee,
that's bitter.
I drink red wine, that's bitter.
They're not poisonous."
They're not, but the compounds in those foods
that make them bitter, if you ate enough of
those compounds, you could die.
Of course, you'd have to eat a lot of coffee,
you have a drink a lot of red wine.
So we generally don't ingest enough.
But what bitter indicates is that there's
something happening pharmaceutically or there's
some medicinal thing going on.
There are bioactives that are good for us
in certain doses, maybe not so good for us
in megadoses.
Most medicines what taste bitter, bitter medicine.
That's because the compounds in there that
are bioactive are tasting bitter.
>>Male #4: What about Brussels sprouts?
>>Stuckey: What about Brussels sprouts?
Pardon?
>>Male #4: Why are they bitter?
I haven't heard of anyone overdosing and dying--
>>Stuckey: [laughs] You'd have to eat a lot
of Brussels sprouts in order to overdose on
Brussels sprouts.
In fact, so much so that I don't think you
could physically get there.
It would be so uncomfortable for you and everyone
around you.
[laughter] So you just don't want to go there.
[laughs] The compound in it, though, if you
extracted that, that's what I'm talking about.
Yes?
>>Male #5: Is it the same with spinach or
green leafy vegetables?
>>Stuckey: Yes.
Most green, leafy vegetables, yeah.
All the things in food that make them healthy
and good for you are bitter.
I know this because we do a lot of work at
Mattson in fortifying foods with things like
antioxidants and polyphenols and flavonols.
All of those things taste extremely bitter.
Salt.
When we're born, we can't taste salt.
Come out of the womb, and we do not have the
mature salt receptor.
Now this terrible story about how we found
out that this is the case is that in Australia,
they used to mix baby formula.
So they'd mix the sugar with the baby formula
and feed it to the kids.
Well, at this hospital, someone mistakenly
sugar with the formula and fed it to the babies.
They drank it like they just drank their normal
formula.
Didn't reject it.
You know when babies don't want something.
They will let you know that they don't want
it.
No response whatsoever from the babies.
The babies drank this incredibly salty formula,
and some of them died from salt poisoning.
Horrible, horrible story.
But we learned that we don't have mature salt
receptors.
But then, at a certain age, they kick in.
And boy, do they kick in.
We love our salt.
Salt obviously provides sodium.
We need sodium for our cell function.
We also need things like calcium, which we
don't really crave in the same way.
We need a lot of other micronutrients that
we don't crave in the same way.
Why do we crave salt this way?
The way that we do?
The reason is we don't have a way to store
sodium in our bodies.
You can take in calcium in your diet, you
can store it in your bones, you can store
it in your teeth.
You take in some sodium, and you can store
it through water retention, but eventually,
you'll lose it.
You'll lose it through crying and sweating
and other excretion from your body.
You constantly need to replenish your body
with sodium.
Of course, that was a hangover from old times
when we used to have to really, really seek
out sodium.
Today, we have easy access to sodium, and
we don't sweat as much, I guess we don't cry
as much, so we don't lose as much.
Now we're taking in more sodium than we need.
You have-- One of your clear cups is labeled
"S", and this is salt.
I want you to just take a sip of the salt
water and remind yourselves what salt water
tastes like.
This is going to be important in a minute.
I find that most people understand four of
the five basic tastes: the sweet, the salt,
the bitter, the sour.
But we're going to get to the last one, umami,
in a minute, which people are a little confused
about.
Okay.
Salt water.
What does it taste like?
Go ahead, take a sip.
>>Female #1: Drink it?
>>Stuckey: No, no, no, you don't have to--
[laughs] Just take enough that you can taste
the salt in it.
Can you taste it?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Stuckey: Yes.
Okay.
That's calibrating your palate.
Calibrating your palate at a certain sodium
level.
Now we're going to move on.
Ah, no, we're not.
I wanted to tell you one more thing about
salt, which is-- and I write about this in
the book.
I have a chapter on each of the basic tastes.
I call salt the superhero of taste.
It is amazing what salt can do.
I mean, I don't really need to tell people
salt's amazing.
We know it's really good.
But the way it works is so cool.
The first thing that salt does is that when
you salt a food, take a tomato, for example,
you upset the cellular balance of that tomato.
What happens is it forces these aroma compounds
out of the cells into the air.
By salting food, you are giving it more aroma,
which gives it more flavor.
Salt not just adds saltiness, it really does
give food more flavor.
The other thing that salt does is-- I call
it the superhero because it suppresses the
bad guys and it lets the good guys run free.
The bad guys of taste being bitter, of course.
A little bit of salt suppresses the bitterness
of something and allows the sweetness, the
good taste, to come forward.
I've got a little wedge of grapefruit there.
I recommend you go home and take a grapefruit,
cut it into wedges, put some salt in a bowl,
and sprinkle salt on half of the wedges.
Take the other half of the wedges, take that
same bowl of salt, add a little touch-- same
bowl of sugar, add a little touch of salt,
and then sprinkle that.
Taste the one with the sugar on it, and it
will taste nice and sweet with a balance of
the salt and the bitter that's naturally present
in the grapefruit.
Then you go to the one that has a little bit
of salt added to the sugar.
It will taste sweeter because the salt is
suppressing the bitterness and letting the
sweetness come forward.
So salt is really the superhero of taste.
>>Female: Quick question.
When it comes to cooking, then, does that
mean you should only salt at the very end?
>>Stuckey: That's a good question.
The question was: should you salt food only
at the end?
Salting the food in the middle of the cooking
process will help marry the flavors.
So yes, I would suggest salting during the
cooking process, but saving some of the salt
so that you do have the ability to do it at
the table.
So I would never add all the salt that you
want in the recipe.
You want to leave a little bit of it out so
you can add it at the very last minute.
Any of those volatile aroma compounds that
are left will be forced out and into the air.
That will give you more aroma, the food more
aroma.
Okay.
Now the fifth basic taste, which is umami.
Umami, of course, is a Japanese word for which
we don't have a really good translation.
We call it brothy or meaty or savory.
We don't have a really good way of describing
this taste, so we borrow the Japanese word.
I'm going to ask our panelists here.
Take the cup with the "U" on it.
That is our umami water.
I've matched the sodium level in the umami
water so I'm going to ask you guys to describe
it.
What does it taste like?
>>Male #1: Seaweed.
>>Stuckey: Seaweed?
Yeah.
>>Male #2: Tasty.
>>Stuckey: Tasty?
>>Female #1: Kombu.
>>Stuckey: Kombu.
>>Male #3: Savory.
>>Stuckey: Savory.
>>Female #2: Disgusting.
>>Stuckey: Disgusting.
[laughs] [laughter] Yeah, it's really odd,
isn't it?
It's very odd.
The reason I do this exercise is that most
of the time when we taste umami, it's in the
presence of a whole lot of other things.
There's aroma that goes along with it, there's
color, there's texture.
What this exercise does is really let you
separate salt from umami, which people get
confused about.
A lot of people will say it tastes like broth.
It might taste like Dashi or it might taste
like chicken broth.
What is giving the umami its umami-ness is
free glutamates.
These are the three forms of glutamates that
we taste: monosodium glutamate, disodium inosinate,
and disodium guanylate.
I'm sure that's clear as mud, right?
Okay, let me explain how umami works.
These are big protein molecules.
I use this analogy of someone putting a huge
gumball or a huge cherry tomato in your mouth.
When it's in that big form, you don't really
get a lot of the flavor from it.
You have to chew it down to release the flavor
from it.
That's what happens with umami.
Through a number of processes, these big protein
molecules are broken down into smaller free
glutamates.
These free glutamates are what taste so yummy.
They are savory, and they're what makes food
taste so good.
So you take cheese.
Let's start with a fresh mozzarella.
Delicious.
Got a nice fatty mouth feel, it melts, it's
got some dairy notes, perhaps a little buttery,
but it doesn't have a lot else going on.
You take a cheese, then you age it.
Over the course of aging, those protein molecules
are broken down into these free glutamates.
Now think about a Parmesan cheese.
You get the big block of Parmesan.
It's crumbly.
That cheese is loaded with free glutamates.
That's why it tastes so meaty.
Sometimes you'll get a good Parmesan or an
aged cheese that has that meaty character
to it.
That's umami.
Take a tomato, a green tomato.
Almost no umami.
Through the ripening process, it will develop
seven to eight times as much umami.
These are the things that help develop that
umami: ripening like the tomato, aging like
the cheese, curing, all those cured meats.
You take the big protein molecules and through
the curing process, you develop the glutamates.
Drying, fermenting.
One of the reasons we love fermented food
so much is the development of these glutamates.
Okay.
So-- yes?
>>Male #6: Evolutionarily, what's the point
of this?
I'm assuming our ancestors didn't have much
chance to eat those kinds of foods.
>>Stuckey: Yes, that's a good point.
There's some debate about whether or not umami
should be considered a basic taste for that
very reason and the very reason that-- What's
your name?
>>Female #2: Naha.
>>Stuckey: --Naha said that it was disgusting
because we generally-- Some of us like it,
some of us don't like it.
We don't really have a definitive, affective
response to it.
The protein doesn't necessarily taste like
umami, but the amino acids do.
Arguably, it was because we need the amino
acids for survival.
Okay.
So now we're going to move on to the next
sense, which is smell.
Everybody take that jelly bean out of your
pocket or your-- What I'm going to ask you
to do is to first of all hold up your right
hand and say, "I promise not to cheat."
>>all: I promise not to cheat.
>>Stuckey: Okay.
All right.
We got that on camera.
Grab your nose and just plug it.
Oh, this is going to difficult right here.
Here, let me.
Put it on your lap.
Okay. [laughs] Gotta plug your nose.
Now the point of this is to disable your sense
of smell.
Go ahead and put the jelly bean in your mouth.
I don't want you to release your nose until
I tell you to.
If you're doing this properly, you should
not smell anything.
So start chewing.
Keep chewing.
Tell me what you're experiencing.
>>Female #2: Kinda sweet.
>>Stuckey: Kinda sweet.
Sweet.
Yeah.
Kinda sweet, that's kinda-- There's not a
lot of basic taste in a jelly bean.
Release your nose now.
[pause] Yeah, okay.
What flavor is it?
>>Male #1: Melon.
>>Stuckey: Melon?
Cantaloupe.
So what you were getting on your tongue, using
just your sense of taste, was sweet because
that's the only basic taste that's in jelly
beans.
Everything else that you smell there, that
whole gestalt of melon, came through your
nose.
That's the aroma.
It's really important to understand where
the sensory input is coming from.
That's-- Now hopefully you've got a good appreciation
for how much of the flavor of food comes from
our sense of smell.
I want to tell you a little bit about a fragrant
flashback, which is my term for how powerful--
one of the examples of how powerful smell
is.
This goes back, again, to the lab at Mattson,
where I was walking from my office to taste
some prototypes.
I have to step back and go back to something
Scott said, which is that I'm from Baltimore.
What you should know about Baltimore is that
when I was growing up, in downtown Baltimore,
the McCormick spice factory was making spices
downtown.
One day, there would be cinnamon in the air
at Baltimore.
And then they'd switch over the lines and
then they'd have basil.
Later in the day would be cumin, and then
later in the day it'd be coriander.
So all of these crazy spices were hanging
in the air in downtown Baltimore.
A random mixture.
We have the spice library at Mattson with
every spice known to man.
One of our interns was in there, taking old
spices and dumping them and refilling them
with fresh spices, because you want to keep
your spices very fresh for the most aroma
impact.
She takes down the cinnamon, dumps it in the
trash.
Basil, dumps it.
Coriander, dumps it.
I'm walking by this trash can and I [laughs]
go over to the trash can and I stick my head
in it.
[deep breath in] Home.
[laughs] What?
So that is the fragrant flashback.
When you smell something and it transports
you to another time.
I know you've all had experiences like that,
where you just smell something and you just
remember something, good or bad.
That is-- There's an anatomical reason for
this.
When any of our senses are detected through
our neurons, through our receptors, the information
goes on its way up to our brain.
It goes through something called the thalamus,
and then it goes on to the brain, and we smell,
or sight, or whatever.
I'm sorry, taste or sight.
Smell does not go through the thalamus.
When you smell something, it goes right to
your brain without making this stop in the
thalamus.
It's a more direct route from sensory experience
to your brain.
We think that is because smell is our most
primitive sense.
But that's also why we have such a direct
connection to emotion when we smell things.
There's two different ways that we smell.
The first way is when we just take something
and we sniff it.
Stick your nose in something and smell it.
That's called orthonasal olfaction.
That's when the smell molecules are going
like this.
The other way we smell something is called
retronasal olfaction.
That's when the smell comes from your mouth.
You put a food in your mouth, you've chewed
the food, and the volatile aromas that are
released from it are sucked up and through
the back of your nasal passages.
They come back past your olfactory receptors
this way.
The quality of those smells this way [sniffs]
and chew chew that way is a little bit different.
We're going to do an exercise now where everybody
take your straw and bend it like this.
Take the long end and put it in your mouth.
See how well they follow the directions.
Okay.
Don't do this yet, but let me show you what
you're going to do.
So I've got something in this cup that is
very aromatic.
The volatile aromas have been building up
in the headspace.
There's a little hole here.
Without looking at it, just take that button,
push it to the side, and stick the short end
of your straw in the hole.
So you're going like this.
Start breathing in and out.
[breathing noises] Just breathe normally.
You smell it?
Don't tell me yet.
You all smell it?
What is it?
>>Male #2: Blue cheese.
>>Stuckey: Blue cheese.
You got it.
Okay.
They did not smell it before it got into their
mouth and went up that way.
That was all retronasal olfaction.
Go ahead and take the lid off and stick your
nose in.
[pause] A little different, huh?
Different.
>>Male #1: It's more strong.
>>Stuckey: It's more strong, for sure, because
you're sticking your nose in there.
The way that we experience these volatile
aromas is slightly different given how they
go in, whether we detect them this way or
that way.
We don't really know why that is, but we know
it happens.
This could also explain why something like
a stinky cheese, a really stinky cheese, may
just smell wrong.
It just smells gross.
Then you put it in your mouth and you chew
it, and it's really pleasant because there's
something different happening.
Now, of course, when you put something in
your mouth and you chew it, you're also using
your sense of taste, and you're probably getting
some saltiness and some sour and maybe a little
bitter.
But you're also getting the mouth feel of
the cheese.
It just coats your tongue.
It's got a nice fatty mouth feel.
So that's smell.
The way that I describe it in the book is
the difference between taste and smell.
It's like a piece of art, because food is
art.
If it's really well made, you have a beautiful
piece of art in front of you three times a
day.
Taste, those five basic tastes, are like the
outlines of the drawing.
They set up the structure of the food.
But if all you had was the basic tastes, like
that jelly bean exercise, all you'd have is
sweet a lot of the time.
All you'd have is sour some of the time.
It's not really that interesting.
But when you add smell, the smell comes and
fills in the details.
And so this art, this beautiful work of art,
becomes what you know it to be, the signature
work of art.
>>Female #1: I have a quick question.
When you have a cold, is it only blocking
that side but it's not blocking the other
side?
>>Stuckey: It's usually blocking both ways
because the mucus in your nose, it's in your
nasal passage.
It doesn't matter which way it's going by,
there's too much mucus for you to be able
to smell it.
It's in the way of the olfactory receptors.
But that's a good question.
With smell, it fills in the details for us.
It gives us the pleasure from food.
Remember, taste is the deciding sense, smell
is the pleasure that we get from food.
Now I'm going to talk about touch and texture.
I'm going to talk about texture in combination
with what you just learned about smell.
You guys have a-- hopefully you have a spoon.
Do you have a spoon on your plate?
>>Male #1: No.
>>Stuckey: No.
Why don't you take this straw and just dip
it in the butter.
What-- oh, there you go.
What everybody has here is-- Just dip the
spoon in and don't eat it yet.
[scraping sound] What they've got is unsalted
butter.
When we're cooking, when we're developing
foods at Mattson, we always use unsalted butter.
If you use salted butter when you take the
amount of butter up in your recipe, you also
take the amount of salt up.
You want to separate those variables so you
can change the variables separately.
This is unsalted butter.
Now take the spoon in one hand and close your
nose with your other hand.
What I'm going to prove to them is butter
has no flavor.
I'm sorry, butter has no taste.
Plug your nose, put the butter in your mouth,
and just swish it around.
[pause] What are you tasting?
>>Male #2: Oil.
>>Stuckey: Oil.
Nothing.
Okay, let your nose go.
Butter, unsalted butter, has zero taste.
There's no sweet, no sour, no bitter, no salt,
no umami.
I always thought of butter as being creamy
and sweet and-- yeah, it's creamy, but it's
not sweet.
It doesn't have any sweetness in it.
What we love about butter is not the taste
of butter.
You don't like the taste of butter because
it has no taste.
What you like about butter is that oily mouth
feel in combination with those lovely, buttery,
floral, green aromas that you get.
Go home and do that tonight with unsalted
butter.
This was such an "Aha!" for me.
Butter has no taste?!
It's crazy.
But we do love the flavor of butter.
>>Male #7: When you brown butter, are you
developing the aromatics or the umami of it?
>>Stuckey: Yes, but that butter also, if you're
using unsalted, will not have any taste either.
No.
You are developing the aroma compounds through
the browning process, but if you hold your
nose, same thing.
You're going to get no taste, no taste, no
taste, fatty mouth feel butter.
All right.
Now we're going to talk about kinesthesia,
which is the awareness of the position and
movement of the parts of the body by means
of sensory organs and the muscles and joints.
This is where texture and touch gets really
interesting because we put food in our mouth
all the time.
We talk while we're chewing and swallowing
without even thinking about it.
It's a pretty amazing thing that we do [laughs]
if you think about it.
We can manage the swallowing, the chewing,
and the breathing at the same time.
How do we know when it's time to swallow?
We just know.
We're aware of the food in our mouth at all
times, but we're not paying attention to it.
But we're aware of it.
That's why we don't choke ourselves to death
when we eat.
We know when it's time to swallow.
If you think about it, next time you chew,
think about what side you're chewing on.
Everybody always has a dominant side, but
you only chew on one side at a time, never
chew on both sides at the same time.
Doesn't happen.
You chew over here, then you push it over
there, then you chew over there, then you
push it over there, then you chew, then you
push it over.
Can't chew on both sides.
It's the only joint in the human body that
you can't operate separately.
You can't do it.
Another experiment for you to do.
There are a couple of foods that I called
irri-tastes because we commonly think of them
as tastes, but they're not tastes at all.
They are actually tactile experiences, and
they are irritants.
The first one is tannin.
If you think of the tannin that you get when
you drink tea that's not sweetened.
Or red wine, a really big California Cabernet,
has tons of tannin.
That tannin will feel astringent on your tongue.
It will dry your tongue out.
It will suck all the moisture out of your
tongue.
That is a textural experience.
That's a tactile experience, not a taste.
It's not bitter.
Now if it's grapes, there might be some bitterness
in there, but the tannic quality of grapes
and tea is not a bitterness, it's an astringent
texture.
Jalapeños.
We love the taste of jalapeños.
Well, actually, jalapeños don't have a lot
of taste.
Might be a little bit sour, but not much.
But what you're experiencing, the burn of
jalapeños, is a tactile experience.
It's working on the same fibers as pain.
Take a fork and jab it into your tongue.
[laughter] [laughs] That's basically what
you're doing when you eat a chili.
We're the only species on Earth that enjoys
food that's painful.
[laughter] But we love it.
It's an irritant.
Coca-cola, sorry, carbonated soft drinks like
that, are irritants.
These little bubbles irritate your tongue.
Now it's a pleasant irritation.
We like it.
But it's an irritation nonetheless.
All right.
Now I've hopefully explained to you the difference
between taste and smell and texture.
Flavor is the combination of all three.
It's the taste.
Back to the chocolate example, the taste of
chocolate is bitter and sweet and maybe fruity
depending on the chocolate varietal or how
it was prepared.
The texture of chocolate is that melty, creamy,
hopefully not too waxy mouth feel.
Then the aromas of chocolate are the lovely
browned, roasted, toasted, beany notes that
we get.
You might get some floral or some fruity notes
as well, depending on the varietal.
That is the flavor of chocolate.
When you talk about the flavor of butter,
you're talking about the combination of taste,
texture, and aroma.
Now we're going to talk about sight.
We're going to talk about how we use our sense
of sight to experience food.
Some of these things are pretty obvious.
If I show you these two steaks, which one
is going to be more tender, the one on the
top or bottom?
Top, obviously.
You knew that right away.
You used your eyes to see that the marbling
is greater.
So you're constantly making these judgments
about food based on its sight.
Sometimes, once you see it and you make a
judgment, it's really hard to change your
mind once something's not quite right.
Beer brewers.
They were brought into a research facility.
There were three beers.
Let's just say one was Amstel, one was Budweiser,
and one was Coors.
A, B, and C. They took three glasses of Amstel
beer, poured them into pints, and then they
added a little bit of color to number 2 and
3 Amstel.
They did the same thing for Bud and Coors.
So you've got three glasses of Amstel in three
different colors, three Bud, three Coors,
three different colors.
Then you have these professional beer brewers
come in and taste them in the dark.
When they're sitting in a dark room and they
have to rely only on their senses excluding
sight, they get them right.
They're beer brewers, they should know how
to taste beer.
Then you turn the lights on.
You have them do the same exact exercise.
And they fail miserably.
These are professional beer brewers that do
this.
What do they do?
They group them by color.
Then you ask them, "Why did you group them
this way?"
"Oh, well they all taste the same.
These all taste the same."
Well, they just did the experiment and got
it right in the dark.
We don't even know when our eyes have overrided
what we experience.
It happens all the time.
This type of research was done with gelatin,
it was done with candies, it was done with
fruity beverages.
You can do it with wine.
There's a very popular, a very famous study
that was done with white wine with a little
bit of red added to one of them so it looked
like red wine.
Same thing.
You can fool wine professionals.
[audience member coughs]
Why?
Why does our eyes, why are they so influential?
There's a couple reasons.
The first is that sight is fast in terms of
processing the sensory input.
Sight happens ten times faster than smell.
If we were able to control it in a perfect
environment, which would be really hard to
do, but if we could control when we smelled
something and when we saw it, we would process
the smell faster.
I'm sorry, we would process the sight faster.
It's faster than the other senses.
The other thing is that sight happens at a
distance.
Back there, you can probably see me, right?
I hope you can't smell me.
You have to be a lot closer to smell something.
You have to be even closer still to taste
it, remember, because taste is a contact sense.
It has to be in touch with your tongue.
So you have these senses that have to be a
whole lot closer to you for you to start making
judgments about it.
The first one that happens, the first thing
you see, biases or infects your ability to
make a good decision.
[pause]
Now this last sense that we're going to talk
about.
I'm going to unplug this so you're without
your sense of sight.
And I'm going to ask you some questions about
[pause] a couple of different audio files.
[noisy file playing] This one's a restaurant.
What do you know about this restaurant?
Do they have an open kitchen or a closed kitchen?
Open kitchen.
It's an open kitchen.
Do they have carpeting?
Do they use paper or plastic or real silverware?
They use real glasses.
They use real silverware.
Is it full?
Pretty full.
So this is-- [pause] [file stops playing]
It's Delfina Restaurant, in the mission, which
is a restaurant that has thought a lot about
its sound.
If you talk to Craig Stoll, the chef owner
there, he will point up and he'll say, "That's
$10,000 worth of sound panels that I've applied
to my restaurant."
He knows very well that sound can have a somewhat
masking effect on flavors.
He talks about his food being authentic Italian
via California, but he says it can't be as
subtle as it is in Italy.
"I have to turn it up."
He actually used that analogy.
"I have to turn the volume up a little bit
to compete with the energy of my restaurant."
He's a very smart restauranteur to know this.
There's some research that was recently done
in the fuselage of an airplane, with jet engines
going.
The people in the airplane experienced food
with the jet engines going, that constant
flum of those engines.
They experienced the food as less salty and
less sweet than they did in the absence of
that noise.
So we know that sound has a masking influence
on tastes and flavors.
We also know that it can pull you in one direction.
We can actually put a bitter taste in your
mouth with the right music, or I should say
the wrong music.
[laughter]
All right.
I have two more audio files.
These are files of me pouring water from a
tea kettle into a cup.
One of these files is hot water, and one of
these files is cold water.
I want you to listen and tell me which.
This is file number one.
[file playing] This is file number two.
[file playing] Which one was hot?
>>audience: The first one.
>>Stuckey: How'd you know that?!
Yes!
Everybody, hundreds of people I've done this
test with, everybody gets it.
How do you know the temperature of water from
sound?
>>audience: [inaudible]
>>Stuckey: You know this.
You're so in tune with the sound of your food.
Incredibly intuned to the point where you
can tell the temperature of water by its sound.
Yet we take this totally for granted.
We don't really think about how much information
we take from the food's sound.
Bite into an apple, and if it crunches one
way, you know it's going to be a good apple.
You bite into it and it crunches the wrong
way, ugh, you know it's not going to be right.
Okay.
In summary, [pause] what I have hopefully
taught you today is just the basic fundamentals.
I have a chapter on each one of the five basic
senses.
All five of which we use incredibly well when
we experience food.
Food that tastes good, using the word improperly,
looks good, sounds good, feels good, smells
good, and tastes good.
Then I have a chapter on each one of the five
basic tastes and go into them in great detail:
sweet, sour, bitter, salt, and umami.
And how understanding how they work and how
they work in balance and how you can balance
the tastes in a food is really important,
because once you get the five basic tastes
right in a dish, the rest is easy.
It's the structure of the dish.
I say once you have this fundamental understanding
of how we experience taste, just like anything
that you study, the more you understand about
it, the more appreciation you're going to
have for it.
The more you study something, the more you
understand, the more pleasure you get from
it.
That is the whole point of this book, is that
you start to understand what's happening via
all of your senses and all of your tastes
and how they're being stimulated.
Then you can take more pleasure from it.
That is all.
Thank you to my five volunteers.
[laughs]
[applause]
>>Male #1: What was this?
>>Stuckey: I have-- Oh, I forgot to-- I was
going to make you tape your nose up.
I have a couple minutes, I think, for questions,
maybe?
Bitter is the indicator.
Bitter is the one that correlates with the
anatomy and the genetic ability to taste.
The other ones follow suit.
So if you do not taste that paper as bitter,
if you just taste it as bitter, you're not
going to taste salt as intensely or sweet.
It follows along exactly.
We don't use the others to test because they
don't-- The bitter one is one that we know
the genetics to that.
We don't know the genetics for the other four
basic tastes.
But they're correlated.
Once we get that one right, we know what the
other ones are going to be.
The second part of your question, which is
can we train ourselves?
Yes, and hopefully that's-- There are a number
of exercises in the book, kind of like these
exercises, which are like the one we did where
we separate salt from umami.
Being able to understand the difference between
salt and umami.
Once you do that exercise, then you're going
to be much more aware of the umami in your
foods.
It's simple training.
One of the hardest things to do is to take
something and just sniff it and know what
it is without seeing it.
That is really hard for chefs to do.
It's just very, very hard.
But people that do it professionally, people
that are in the wine business, for example,
or in the perfuming business, tend to be better
at it.
It does show that practice makes perfect.
For example, when I started in food development,
my colleagues would talk about rancidity and
what was rancid.
I had no idea what rancid was, so I begged
them, "Please let me taste something rancid.
[laughter] Next time there's something rancid,
can you point it out to me?"
I have a little rancid vial, if anybody wants
to smell rancidity.
Because I had to train myself because I wasn't
detecting it.
I didn't know what to look for, what to smell
for.
Now I know, and now-- Olive oil, I can smell
rancid olive oil a mile away.
But 20 years ago, I couldn't.
It's practice makes perfect.
Really, really, really does help.
>>Male #8: Does the practice makes perfect
principle hold true for foods you don't like?
Like Brussels sprouts?
[laughs]
>>Stuckey: Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Research has shown that it takes between five
and eight attempts at a food before not rejecting
it.
That doesn't mean you're going to become,
after the fifth or the eighth taste, you're
going to become the world's biggest fan of
Brussels sprouts, but keep trying it.
Give yourself a couple of times.
Your taste buds and your olfactory system
change dramatically as you age, so you might
decide, if you keep trying it, keep trying
it every couple of months or every season,
every Brussels sprout season, try it again.
As you age and your olfactory changes, you
may be able to experience it with less of
the sulfury smell or you may be able to experience
it with more sour and less of the bitter.
Your whole physiology with regard to taste
changes.
So I would suggest continuing to taste.
>>Male #8: So there are two pieces to it?
There's the degree which I can affect it by
consuming it formally--
>>Stuckey: Yes.
It's called mere-exposure.
It's just the mere exposure to something.
I'll give you an example.
When I started in the Mattson lab 15 plus
years ago, I hated canned tuna.
Just the smell of canned tuna was disgusting
to me.
Then I get a tuna project.
For four years, I ate tuna every day.
I had to.
I tasted canned tuna every day.
I love tuna today.
I love it!
Because I can-- I don't like every kind of
tuna.
I like good tuna.
And I'm discriminating now about my canned
tuna.
I like the once cooked and not the twice cooked,
and I like the albacore and I don't like the
light.
So mere-exposure will help.
>>Male #8: Okay, great.
Thank you.
>>Female #2: Have you tried a stinky tofu
or durian?
>>Stuckey: Yes.
I think-- the question was: have I tried stinky
tofu or durian?
I think durian is, I think there's something
similar that happens with durian that happens
with a stinky cheese, which is the orthonasal
smell of durian is just-- If you haven't smelled
it, it's kinda like rotting flesh, like garbage,
sewage.
It's just really rank.
But people love it.
So something different happens when you eat
it.
Of course, when you eat it, now you're not
just getting-- What happens, I think, is when
you're smelling it, all you're getting are
those rank odors, and you get them one way.
Then you put the fruit in your mouth.
Now you've got sweet and sour basic tastes,
because now you can use your sense of taste.
So you take that rank odor and you combine
it with the sweet and the sour that you get
from taste, and now it's something different
altogether.
Maybe things start to fall in place.
There are a lot of foods like that, where
we think that the smell is just so-- Stinky
tofu comes up all the time.
Just unbearable.
But taste it.
If you put it in your mouth, if you can get
it into your mouth, you will have a different
experience of it.
Of course, a lot of this is cultural, too.
Stinky cheese is.
You grow up in France, and a stinky cheese
shop smells really good to you.
[pause]
>>Male #9: So my daughter says that kale is
the most hideous thing ever.
>>Stuckey: Kale?
>>Male #9: Kale.
And my wife is convinced that is has no taste
at all.
You can't even tell it's there.
How can I let them know that they're both
right?
That they both have different taste experiences?
>>Stuckey: What you've just described is what
I hope people take away from this book, which
is taste empathy.
[laughter] We have to have taste empathy.
Really, we don't talk about it in this country.
Like it's okay for us to say, "I can't see
that over there because I don't really have
good eyesight" but yet we don't accept the
fact that one of our other senses can vary
from person to person.
Right?
We all have different vision, different visual
acuity.
What I think happens, or is happening in your
household, is your wife is a tolerant taster,
meaning she has probably a very not so densely
populated tongue, with taste buds, and she
genetically is probably also unable to taste
the bitterness in kale.
She might be right.
To her, in her private sensory world, kale
is crunchy and fresh and vegetal and not bitter.
Then in your daughter's sensory world, it
might be the most bitter thing she's every
put in her mouth.
And they're both right.
You're exactly right.
They're both right.
Of course you can never know what-- another
person's sensory experience.
You should do that at home.
Take the blue dye and paint your daughter's
and your wife's tongue and then have them
count the taste buds inside the hole of the
reinforcement.
They can prove it to themselves that they
have very different anatomy.
That hopefully will give your wife some taste
empathy.
>>Male #10: Is it big enough to count?
>>Stuckey: Yes.
You're just going to need to get really close
to a mirror.
But watch out, because blue dye stains carpets
and towels.
I found this out the hard way.
[laughs]
>>Male #11: Along those lines, I was wondering
if you have any explanation, specifically
for why some people claim that cilantro tastes
like soap?
>>Stuckey: I always get this question.
Always get this question.
Cilantro is a really interesting thing.
In the food world, we call it polarizing.
You just don't sit on the fence about cilantro.
You either love it or you hate it.
[laughter] We know a lot about cilantro.
We know that there is a genetic component
to your liking of cilantro.
The way we know this is that we do research
with twins.
There's this place in Ohio called Twinsburg.
Every year, they have a twin festival.
All these twins go there.
The researchers are just drooling at the mouth,
because they can take a set of fraternal twins
and a set of identical twins and test something.
Of course, you can determine, by the correlation,
whether or not there's a genetic component
to it.
If the correlation is perfect for the identical
twins who share 100% of their DNA but not
for the fraternal twins, who don't, in fact,
they're just like any other set of siblings,
you know there's a genetic component to it.
We know there's a genetic component to the
liking of cilantro.
The other thing that we know about cilantro--
There's been a lot of research on this subject.
This is such a polarizing food.
What apparently happens is that when you run
cilantro through the GCMS, the gas chromatograph
mass spectrometer, which is what you can run
something through to get the volatile aroma
menu out of it.
You expose someone to the smells that occur
in cilantro.
There is an aroma experience that people who
love cilantro get, that people who don't,
don't get.
The same thing.
People who hate it, they're smelling different--
When you run something through this GCMS,
it gives you spikes in volatile aromas.
There are certain things, certain volatiles
in the cilantro, that people that hate it
are not experiencing.
There are certain things in there that people
who love it are not experiencing.
So they're getting different pictures of it.
They're not-- Neither one of them is getting
the same picture as the other.
This is true of cilantro.
It's probably true of a lot of foods.
But there's been a lot of research done on
cilantro.
That is that your personal experience of the
aroma of cilantro may be very different than
someone else's.
The beautiful stuff that makes it beautiful
to you may not occur, may not be happening,
in someone else's experience.
Or the disgusting part that you find really
offensive may not be experienced by people
who at it.
>>Female #3: Going back to your early comment
about sound in restaurants, does that mean
that if you're a really good chef, you should
try to get a really, really quiet restaurant,
and if your food's not so good, you should
have it as loud as you want, blare loud music,
and everything?
>>Stuckey: I don't think it's that literal.
I hope chefs don't take it as that literal.
Of course you want appropriate sound in your
restaurant.
You want to pair the sound and the music with
the food.
It needs to be appropriate.
I think what chefs try to do, or what restauranteurs,
I don't know that it's chefs necessarily,
what restauranteurs try to do is build ambiance
into the restaurant.
They try to build energy into the restaurant
via sound.
That can work in some cases where the food
can stand up to it and where you want that
energy.
There are other restaurants where the food
is much more subtle, and you want people to
experience the subtlety of it, which probably
wouldn't work.
It's so different for every experience, every
restaurant, every chef, every owner, and every
type of food.
It's just-- What I'd like people to think
about is just think about it, period.
Just think about the sound of food, which
we just don't think about those two things
together.
>>Giambastiani: All right, well, I think that
wraps up our time for right now.
We'll have some time for more questions at
the book signing.
But Barb, thank you very much for speaking
with us today.
>>Stuckey: Thank you.
Thank you guys for having me.
[applause]